we've got some big news coming in today
in the fight to get back to normal
wouldn't that be great
amid this pandemic we're expecting
updated guidelines from the federal
government about
who should be wearing masks and when a
federal official tells cbs news that the
new cdc guidelines will lay out what
activities
fully vaccinated people may resume so
that includes when and
if it's necessary to continue wearing
the mask outdoors
currently cdc guidelines say the mass
may not be necessary outdoors if you're
away from
others or if you're only with people
from your household
also today president biden will give an
update on the state of the pandemic
a briefing from his covet 19 response
team will likely discuss
all of these new guidelines health and
human services secretary javier becerra
joins us now secretary becerra good
morning to you
we are at a crucial juncture uh in
combating covet 19
and we've got these new mass guidelines
coming down uh your department oversees
the cdc so i want to put the question to
you
first what we can expect and also it
sounds like it's going to be organized
around
whether or not a person is vaccinated or
not which i would read as a kind of
encouragement to get more people out
there
to get that vaccination fair to say yeah
good morning and thanks for having me
and absolutely uh the message is clear
you're vaccinated guess what you get to
return to a more normal lifestyle if
you're not vaccinated
you're still a danger you're still in
danger as well so get vaccinated
a cbs poll finds that while we are
making
improvements in the numbers of people
willing to get vaccinated there is still
a hardened core of about
between a quarter and a fifth of the
population saying
no way i know you're working on that
population but
what's your level of frustration that
we've reached a point where we may not
be able to make any more inroads
well remember when you get 130 million
americans fully vaccinated two-thirds of
all seniors today are fully vaccinated
that's all good news we want to build on
that we want others to join them
because when they join them being
vaccinated they can join them outside
and not have to wear masks secretary i
want to go back to the mass thing for
just a second because i've often
wondered
i'm outside by myself nobody's around
why am i wearing a mask
so this would be very helpful to know if
you're vaccinated
do you have to wear a mask outside or
you don't have to wear a mask outside
well we weren't born with masks but we
want to be safe and we want to protect
our loved ones
and so that's why we wear masks right we
put on our seat belt we don't expect
that we're going to crash our car
but we want to be safe that's what we're
just trying to do is make sure everyone
is safe
we want to get back to a normal
lifestyle we want to get our economy
going people back at work
restaurants open you got to do that the
right way and masks help
vaccinations important masks help and so
even though i'm
i've been vaccinated i still wear a mask
exactly so why do you why do we have to
do that if we're vaccinated that's why
i'm so confused
because i keep hearing you don't have to
wear it but still you could still
pass it or you could still pass it along
even though you've been vaccinated
that's why i'm confused yeah the vaccine
has done a really good job of making
sure
you'll not only be safe and healthy but
that you won't affect others but still
we you never know and what you're trying
to do is encourage others
we're going to get to a point where
masks we're going to hang or
hang up masks on our wall as as you know
signs of what used to be but until then
let's let's try to get to the point
where we're back to normal mr secretary
nearly 30 percent of covid cases are
among hispanics
and they make up less than 20 percent of
the population what's being done to get
the vaccine to the hispanic communities
oh great question because we're trying
to reach all those folks from who are in
hard-to-reach places and so many of the
workers
in america who were classified as
essential workers were latino
and so we're trying to get to them where
they are instead of
waiting for them to come to to the sites
where there's vaccinations opportunities
we're trying to go to them and that's
what we're doing throughout the country
we're doing that in rural areas because
we know a lot of americans
find it very difficult to get some of
these vaccination sites
we're going to go to where people are
we're going to make enough supply of
vaccinations
vaccines available and we're going to
make sure that we get everyone
vaccinated mr secretary i'd like to
shift topics
if we could to the border crisis there
are still record numbers of migrant
children unaccompanied arriving at the
u.s border
and where hhs comes into the picture is
after apprehension
the children are moved to a shelter and
then moved to a sponsor family the
shelter and the sponsor family that's
that's your department
uh how close are those shelters right
now to capacity
well pretty much at capacity and because
as you said they keep coming we keep
having to find more space
what we're trying to do is do this the
legal way the responsible way the right
way these are kids
and regardless of what their ultimate
outcome whether they're returned to
their home country
or not we have an obligation at hhs to
make sure we take care of their health
and their well-being while they're
temporarily with us mr secretary what do
you need
most right now to address that crisis do
you need more shelter space or do you
need more people to help you place these
kids with sponsor families
a little bit of both and uh what we're
finding is that we are
looking for as many of those places with
beds
that are licensed that have the
caregivers who are accustomed to
treating kids
and where we can't we still know it's
better to put them in our care
than keep them at the custom border
patrol centers because they're not
equipped to handle kids and so
we're going to do what's right by these
kids while they're temporarily with us
mr mr secretary the biden administration
does appear to be a little reluctant
to let the media cameras into these
facilities how come
well remember you're talking about
children these are not adults
they have privacy protections whether
you're an american citizen
or a migrant child seeking asylum you
have privacy protections you're not
you're not open to just the public to
identify you at the same time remember
covet still is out there and we can't
have people co-mingling
because we don't want to spread covet so
it's strictly a health issue and a
privacy issue
because some people say transparency
would help here
yeah oh we're all for that and we will
continue to open the sites
where it's possible when it's possible
when we can do it
reasonably but first and foremost safety
and well-being of those kids
privacy protections and making sure we
don't spread covet
all right secretary baser we appreciate
you getting up early for us this morning
thank you very much